I say exclusivity agreement as well,
and I explain what it means.
If they say they don't do contracts, I call BS.
We have credit cards.
We hand credit cards to teenagers
in drive throws all the time.
The exclusivity agreement is for the protection of the BO.
Yeah. Good point, Mahmood.
It is true.
You don't need to call it a contract.
Call it an exclusivity agreement.
If they say, hey, can I cancel?
Then you can say, no.
You can say however you want, but no, obviously not.
But if you want to find somebody to replace you
for the rest of those months, you can.
But no, we don't do that.
You know, that kind of a thing.
But guys, just be confident.
When you say something, be confident,
and they'll be confident if you're timid.
Well, yeah, there is, but then it's not gonna work.
Okay?
Call it an exclusivity agreement.
Call it a contract.
Nobody cares.
Just be confident with what you say.
Got it? Francesca, you got it?
I got it.